well we're back in this
developers 2013 edition bogotá we are
on the day of the back-end we continue
developing internal services
each of the groups continues
very concentrated
hating generating a solution how is
you cited as among the successes
I much much much of careers we have
here and of course of course because
We are as I told you living in state
the technological what each one of the groups
they are still concentrated watching details of
the internal part of the solution that
they are developing continue to be refined
the ideas are still being discussed
course the business model and how
would work this this new solution with
with benefit for the first regional
is that in minutes nothing else we will be
playing with the groups we are also going to
be analyzing as we did in the
first in our living too
doing school use cited school
the technological test let's say so
well also here I already have my side to
my right of course francisco paco
how are you
down I think everything is going smoothly
some teams look very serious
serious very serious really are very
serious very concentrated each of the
team we are going to review is coming
also the game of soccer within the
level or probos 2013 or if they are serious
you have to decontract the ones that
descontracturar they told us that in
colombia good soccer is played
let's play soccer with the teams
with the participants and the challenge has
to see who wins the challenge I do not know
if you have the challenge of course you stay
without the code revision or it is zafa
session 6 of the code review but
whoever loses it, whoever loses it, let's
check your code in the repository
grassi pulse because undertaken live
so very interesting for that for that
what are we going to see in this live
it has to do with computen sin sigue
computing without and you will also see something
from the tools we also had
pending from
the day of the front on the stage of the
clown point let's also see something of
clown point because they have to see
also with the cloud and today is our day
of the back-end so important that
keep in mind that you are there
connected that is following no minutes
minutes of course of what we're going to
talk technically in this live and for
of course all the interaction that is lived
in this developer bus 2003 edition votes
we also remind you that you can get
all the information you can see everything
what happens in this developer bus 2013
in the portal develop point with
Google com
join the community developers
because there is a lot of information too
that has to do with minute by minute
that has to do with what the teams
are doing in interaction
community as always we
we do here in this video but look and
of course from google developers
what pacos we already have more than 12,000
following people if it is indeed if not
you are still in this one the page
we invite you to go there are photographs of all
the equipment is a description of what
they are working and it would be great that
vote for them
the rating is part of what we
will take silicon valley with the rest
of the winners of the region
exactly as Paco says
It has to do with that, you can vote for
each group can say which
it's your favorite that you think you can
leave your comments and you can also
participate with us live as
did you also joel from mexico in
our first day of the challenge so
Sing collaborate and communicate with the
community so communicate live
with us of course so
we have a lot of information to tell you
we already have our technical framework
theoretical framework we are also going to talk about
competition and let's talk about those of
tools let's do some examples with
that we're going to start talking about
assumption of the infrastructure as
service many social news you can
chat with us you can leave your
comments you can vote for the groups and
help them get to silicon valley
also because it's part of the
qualification as francisco said
seconds ago, you can follow it
in the developer community and
let's enjoy this video so
we heat engines we prepare not you
lose soccer football well here in
colombia in bogota with the participants
all right
the technical scenario in seconds so
we heat engines and we're back with
much more money but bosch 2013 edition
Bogota
hello good morning my name is michael
martin I am from group 7 of our ideas
displays the most difficult challenge we had
and yesterday on the first day of development
was formalize the idea hello I'm jacob and
sasha this is the team 6
business yesterday we had a very bacano challenge
that was to create the entire business idea to
messing up we feel really good hello my
name is leader
our group is agronomy
yesterday we felt good feeling of
my excellent part therefore working with
the group as the group shows that
we have a lot of talent to exploit
and get a quality product and then
that can really win is the
competition
and so
the biggest challenge I say that for us
can try to define the actual scope
of the application that we wanted then to
Early in the day we had 10,000 ideas
if it touched us
polish to leave something more or more
achievable for the time that I too
I think that after more retouching and these
two days left alone
give hard to that idea
but my name is or more pray I am the uncle
of recycling recycle yesterday's did not
we feel super good with all the dynamics
and our greatest challenge has been to be able
integrate the google applications of
a very very easy way to our
integration platform project
to recycle
we continue in 2013 edition Bogota comes the
moment of the technical challenge the successes
I want you to come with me, sorry, let's go
continue to develop
csc while we thank the people of
the community that is following us
Arisbel from Mexico mechas mayerlis
I hope I have pronounced your name well
from the university of Quindío force
to the teams thank you
Arming picón already started the t3 bogota
everything is in order, in effect we are
here live
what a barbarian if the defense along
all Latin America
there's a great one we have to read this
hugo garza I think it's almost impossible
see the tempus bogota and at the same time
the game of portugal and sweden and at the same
time to work
are there priorities please please hugo
Bogota for his accompanied by course
keep enjoying this
developer bus 2013 bogotá bueno let's go to
technical challenge that we have I do not know if you
it seems that we have to analyze in this
context has to do with complutense
in itself the infrastructure solution
as a service proposed by google
We will quickly show you the console
we have all projects always
we name the same cloud with sun or
page console that was modified to
the cloud console now that we have
we can generate different types of
projects these types of projects by
course they have activations for example
I'll show you the first one if
we have an overview if where we can
see all the spice activated in this
case we have for example close that
store on foot and cloud messaging good
various types of foot and we have by
course activated google compute without
order to make use of the solution
of competition of course at first
case I have to have it activated on
service then it follows is maintained as
we always talk about it and what
we comment we have the part of
authorization
to service of course if I go to
have to connect what I'm going to have to
do through open authentication or
some of the mechanisms that we have
allowed good in this way look
I'm going to show you we have several types
of projects in this project that this
project has some of the hype
deactivated
let's see but does not have zinc computen
to this one also has converts lead to
look for one that does not have activated by
example surely you do not have it
all projects have a number of
identification and in this way we can
go locating and seeing how to interact
with that service
in this particular case, notice that
we only have close thorax and not
we have another of the activated services
what we are going to do for this demo is
go find one of the projects
that you can generate a new
project in this way activate the
service that they require in this case
We are going to activate computer ying
to make use of the infrastructure
as a service make use of the machines
virtual that google gives us in this
case in which I can deploy it what
that comes to mind basically speaking ok
here we have notice that I already have use of
cpu and use of networks since already something of use
of disc also from any of the
instances that I have costed here in
as in competition today will enter
compute zinc and you can observe
here I have different machines
virtual team these virtual machines
as you can see here I have one that
flame bogota
in this particular case it also has a
disc that is called boot and good has
a configuration
notice that if I wanted to for example
upload and use more instances within
this engineering project more machines
virtual and in this way I could continue
operating or launch processes or perform
any activity that comes to mind
ask for a name sample name if by
example here I have a description for
put I'm generating a machine and
this instance can be like you
are seeing here already or an instance of
one of a mental machine linux in this
case with well distribution could
put metadata tags if you could choose the
area where I would like to operate this
because I could choose center zones of
data and specifics depending on what
location have more consumption to achieve
better latency or a lower one
latency in this case of development or of
use also note that here I
I choose the type of machine I would like
use in this case I can use in
this case I am using one of a
only cpu if with 38 gigabyte of memory
but I could choose something more powerful or
something less powerful
of course discs if I could choose
discs and in this way can be
using and what image is it that I
I want to deploy in the virtual machine
some of the images are available
there could be others are also going
permanently updating this
way I can keep my machine
updated virtual
note also that you could choose another
of the disks as additional discs
configure my network in this case we are going to
use we can use an ip
static also or an ip assigned from
good way by the service in tiff
other access parameters that you could
configure the virtual machine and already the
would leave ready to give you create as
I will do at this precise moment
this takes a few seconds
until the virtual machine rises
is generated and in this way is already
operative we are going to let
generating the can see here
and we're going to make use of the one we already have
configured pre-configured that is the
Bogota and how do I access these
virtual machines and deploy services
and we're going to make the first point that
we consider ourselves good I'm going to
use I can do it through ssh
I'm going to use a console if there are
very simple tools that we
also proposes the competition team
I'll show you here in second
and that I know that here we have him
the giving is proposing us
basically how to go lifting
instances and in this way go
configuring the headlights I did not show them
but now I'm going to enter the instance or
set a bluff I can change the
network configuration that way to have
my totally chaste machine made it
I want to choose your machine
directly exactly then to this
machine I can deploy is a linux
so I can explain the service
who wants and I can perform the operation
who wants that is the fundamental point
of this one now we're going to use this one
these tools if it is useful and
if they want to see it that way and if it's useful and this
way with command language in a
console basically a chat I can
connect me like I'm going to do this good
notice that here we have a step by step and
where he configures the project and I go
accessing in different ways I have
a previous configuration of keys
let's say to be able to authorize myself and that the
service recognize me in this way
to be able to continue working
quickly here
to consolidate I will use the
tools that I mentioned
let's hot that is used in this case
I'm going to tell you that I'm going to
connect me by ssh and we will tell you
that I'm going to connect to the machine
Bogota
in this case I am entering
through the cch as you can see and
at this precise moment I am already inside
of the virtual machine xi so I'm
operating in seconds it generates a
instance is distance I have it ready is
a virtual machine and that way already
I have my server on the internet and I can
unfold an apache if I wanted to I can already
put it to work and I will place my
html on my website what I would like
in this way fully operational ok
good as you can see I'm going to
navigate inside this server
look
Ron
to this in the home I will make a list
of this yes as I have here to patch
installed in this case yes but I already
I show of course in second I'm going to
show how they install themselves very quickly
a being a patched patch service
this case I will go to one of the
directories that I have that is the bar
where they are publishing
the sites here I can go to double-double
yes and notice that I am enrolling here
I already have an index html is the service or
be the html by default the index that
raise the apache service the idea is
that we see that html index and that we can
detect as it is already is
working if the machine is already
virtual the apache is already installed and
I can quickly access the service
through the public ip truth
then let's quickly see this yes
and we return to our console notice that
I have my virtual machine here we go to
enter
the virtual machine of bogota
here I have look at internal ips of
I manage and I have a static ip so
I put it external which is 8.35 point 192
point 133 let's go point be here
and here the first thing we see when
we enter saying that it is unique and public
of course he is raising the
my virtual machine's apache service
that I just generated seconds ago
prior to the one I showed you
I already have the hello war but the idea is
that we can we are inside the machine
virtual that we can modify that html
which is very simple and that way
change hello or hello world by the
hello world or hello bogota so
whether we go there I need under the pac
can be also take hello paco what
let's try to put the pac
well then I'm in here
now notice that you could how could in
first moment of editing would be inside me
linux what options do I have to edit
shtml that I could use I'm in
a devia
no longer
nano index.hu ml ok
there I am seeing already my html that is says
hello world so what could I do
is to come and change and say hello paqui
true an army works
then there I have the opaque good let's go
to write this yes and what happened
step that I do not have write permissions
How could I give my virtual machine
write permissions that is the question
that we have to do in
this particular case as we could
do you quoted what you think it does
I do not know, I say, I ask everyone to
diego 2013 that could be I'm inside
I linux what option I have to be able
operate with this I would say if you know that
for them to do it to see who is
encourages me to do it for myself or someone
of the talents of colombia is encouraged to
doing it for me is a line what there is
to modify just I know there's a lot
people working with complutense
we raise a virtual machine to that
virtual machine was installed the
service that we will now do in
seconds next to voice of the new machine
virtual and then the only thing we did is
navigate to the place where you publish the
apache and in this way modify a
simple super simple html note what
fast for ccoo can innovate people
your virtual machine can be generated can
put the number of processors of
memory that wants good of those that there
available a Linux distribution
fully flexible deploys a
application and I already have it operational
lift up the brave hot hand do
this earns a kit so that they are not a
kit let's go with the paco kit what happened
so
he is a courageous mentor that they raise had
that being a mentor does not work
is cheating bogotá they are
cheating what I did
make him a sweat nothing else either I put
obviously as admin so it's simple you
I told nano what is the file what and
is and notice what happened Mr.
I knew it and I know that you knew I was
sure they knew it but they do not cheer up and
they lost just right this a
trip to california exam what a pity
but well, it's very much you who are
there of course concentrated because it
had concentrated watching competing without
quickly good now we show you
write these three lines I said hello
paco be good once
we already wrote this then we're going to
get out of here I keep on the console what
what would have to happen is that
when I changed if I refresh
appeared the changed box appeared on
blackout and appeared the peace that I am good
because if you look and the blackout did not appear
then very simple very simple
We show how to use this console
how to use competition to
get up a new virtual machine
now look at the quick start yes that
we have of course the step to
step where we go to you auto
authorizing to use another of the
virtual machines imagine that
we want to authorize another of the
machines and what are we going to do then I
I'm going to use another one with solita
here we have
let's see again the utilities for
course we are going to enter by ssh and we are going
to look for us to generate a
new a new instance
in computing and we had generated a
that is called true example that has
flu good then let's go back to
our example
in this way try to connect us by
ssh to that second instance of which
we were talking good here
we are connected to the second instance
and I promised them we were going for
course to try to install good
notice that it could generate a firewall
could perform different types of
configurations but the idea by
course is to install apache notice I'll
to use again a sudo
let's see ok and there we are installing
Apache are first making a law of
the packages and now we're going to install the
apache 20
so it's simple to notice that I in three
clicks in four clicks with the console
I'm installing and leaving configured
if the new virtual machine there is what
we make it that simple
and we are when that process ends
I have apache 20 running I'm going again
to browse the system file edit
what what is necessary and this
way forward the process of
innovation that we are seeing that a
Sometimes yes, I want to generate a
solution I want it to be scalable I want
that has infrastructure that gives me
support so simple very fast with
compete zinc I register the service
and I really have everything available for
How did you see that great or what is
Extremely easy to do things since they saw it
and they can also combine perfect all
the cloud computing in app platform
engine etc. then
and then there are games a little more complex
how to tell or what is there from computen
without going to consume pain without from app
in without I can delegate things in
competition we are going to see also in the
tomorrow we are going to be
integrating let's see prediction but
we go
close and what is the scenario of
relational as if it were the same let's say
in the cloud then this way I
I can also interact between
relational repositories go to data
store does not necessarily relate
equal and use the infrastructure of
cloud and use it the solution of
platform that is what we
we call the cloud platform that is
delivering google and that really is very
useful and it's very good that you know him
if we present compete singh yes
we accomplish success very quickly how
unite you know you're there connected
Of course you can converse with
we could there be any question the
You can do so that the answer is sent
for its access by its buses and I'm
speaking of that, look there's
requests for the camera hidden in
two teams ask us to cooperate followed
recícme ok ok let's go if the spy camera
is out there is the spy camera
prepared so we're going to take some
seconds we will continue heating
engines will come football with the
participants so attentive is coming
code review we will continue
sharing with you of course all
google technology all the
cloud technology on the day of
back-end so for ccoo we
we prepare if we heat engines and
we are back in seconds with much more
unveiled but bosch 2013 edition little such
we'll be back
It was a great experience when a lot
people we made the groups was a challenge
present at the end of the day everything
we had progressed and thus present them
in front of so many people on YouTube
it was a little bit scary
true but then there we go and then we go
to make the group winner the number
four
thank you good yesterday was very
interesting because there were quite a lot of challenges
first of all, how to model the
idea that we had the skills of
each of the group members for
what could we do fast
simple and how it works then was a
interesting experience because you can
get to see how it's always like
positive any change and see how the
the skills of each person
we feel well happy
we are a little bit tired two a
little in sleep but it does not matter
today it is right to give it and I think tomorrow
if we are going to be
Hi, I'm Mario Moreno and I'm from the team
Claudio
yesterday I felt very good with a lot
energy is the team gave everything
of fish one ear all I had to
do in his role I dedicated myself to design
the brand
in the application that we are going to do and the
challenge was to take that presentation in less
half an hour and to have it ready and we
it was very well I think that we very well
I feel we are confident and we are going
to win
well my name is diana on the day of
yesterday it really was a great experience
I met a lot of people we made groups
it was a challenge to present at the end of the day
everything that we had progressed and then
present it in front of so many people in
youtube well it was a bit gives a bit of
fear the truth but was saved
well, we came back in this nursery
probos 2013 bogotá edition we are
living together with the groups of course
all islanders technology all the
implementation framework of the backend if
the internal services but I need
we have surprises for the imprisoned doctor
I told him we're going to play football with the
participants let's see what it is
try the challenge because whoever loses if
with me and with good paco let's review
the code and they're going to lose all
you football are very good we are going to
see here in mexico and argentina against
colombia so well this is already put
let's see what happens if good very
interesting but his successes yes to see
they told me that there is chat with paco
We were talking about Roche
requests about the spy camera is
the spy camera out there is the camera
you can spy on the groups we're going to
spy on the groups of seems to like
excellent and good I'm watching let's
see you quoted I'm already seeing there
we are seeing the groups you see a
notebook
and there comes
they are doing promotion ay ay ay ay
ay ay
We were spying on the groups but
it seems that they realized
and they keep walking not of those good ones is
part of our whole audience here
where we are having a good time is
developer station here at the university
of course here in Bogota so for
I bark it
look and there if we keep waiting
if you're good and we've been spying there
we continue in the same course and one ear and
what a barbarian an ear is happening that
spy camera of course we invite to
you are there connected with
we
you want to spy on the groups you want to know
much more than what is happening with
each of the projects can
request it of course leave your
commentary
and good spy camera
we also want to answer there
Arming is asking if I can
unfold if of course you can
deploy lots of services
between those and also to keep if
you want your web repository
the code repository scenario
open source or whatever you want if
also virtual machines of course
yes, so we are also
answering questions we have some
other comments we are still waiting for
the groups and we are there
for sanz says it's the project plan
cloud
very well
and the most interesting part of his
manager program that is very good in the
speeches about the platform
I know that we are going to look for
to the claudia group we're going to talk
with your manager program also for
answer you who are connected
Isaac Isaac pass true so maybe
that we're going to answer of course
to go see what is happening with the
group while we keep spying on us
we are spying ain we show inventors
from work I see a lot of food I do not know if
you know there are teams that
we were wondering you saw the cuts
how they were motivated and everyone did
with food they watched he ate very well
we're going to ask
the groups to you what interests you
you are connected with us to see
what is that about we also have very
concentrated to the people there writing
very good very good really the
We are having a great time in this nursery
own 2013 but it's time for the
challenge to 12 quoted if I'm going to
prepare little voice I'll prepare if
I'm going to ask you to come with me
let's talk to the groups yes because
while I am watching and accompany me though
I am also here the arc of the
football we will have to select two
groups for ccoo I think the group already
the group stated that they can well
be a woman so we select a
three groups that's your choice yes and I
while I'm putting the bow here and we're going
to compete of course for the review
of code so I kept looking at me I put together
the arch that we already have here we are going to
play are chosen pre-elected ok sax
who will come to compete with us
here we have the arc already armed you like
little voice look that of course
nicb shortcut in playing is small
bow no of course no no no no I
run the bow the bow is running me
no no of course so it's the
We are ready now
be prepared come to one of you who is going
to come to play soccer with
we go very well perfect already
we have almost everything armed so for
course they have good 13 and also
also good is going to play carolina
carolina iván yes and teach and william
good follow us let's play with them 3
we project the one that I can not get a
goal will get me the review of
code so it's super simple simple
we'll see
the little one is going to kick with this one because
it's logical if you make room for me there
I'm going to come follow me around here
We are going to be
Carefully, we broke nothing
supposedly good I would not try it up
because even what is appetite let's see if
keep that can be the review this
can happen anything new that
is there of course you can vote it
comes the goal or does not come speak
something will come carolina iván and the lord and
guillermo william good review
of the code so you can kick
quiet
review I say here, so for ccoo
what do you think about argentina view 1 colombia
0 good we go very calm they come
for here sir you are going to kick with
is because it is the biggest, that is,
course yes you live out there to see
what do you think Guillermo is going to kick
we go
how I feel is already looking for the
experienced so do not worry what
I will do everything
an applause for the second good
the three revisions of Argentine code
two colombias but good to see what happens
this is very simple of a problem
low low good we win then as
you will see if this was the most honest
possible if your image of the challenge and you
come three code reviews for
what did you think about it, I think someone
can enter but I hope you think we're looking
we look for a 1 more
one more group it seems to you that you're
there who wants to score goal and save himself
the coaching review we already follow
spying on the camera we already follow
spying on the camera and there they are sending
nobody is and neither are they for me
I'm scared with that camera and really
it's very interesting but you can
vote also to see
You want me to kick who you want to
you who follow the camera is selecting
people is also really very
interesting
we're going to do something
come forward colombia
let's do it will be easier andrea is going to
have to do little games and if he succeeds
do three little games together if 3
from the floor he lifts
very easy and with the knee is
cheating but hey if he manages to be
four four in a row tac tac tac tac
if the code revision is saved
well almost almost very well andrea too
the revision of codes with the last
paco the last one looked for the ball yes to see
if someone because we finish 40 for now
yes it reminds me of old times
let's say the camera follows
selecting in the camera is
selecting the applause
well you're going to have to do 25 25 with 5
is fine with 5 is well behind no
break nothing is not known if the little game
down
already go 4 to 0 juan manuel the lift and
makes little games tac tac 1 2 3 4 5
it's all source code like bénabar 2 3 4
pity did not reach the 25 or 95 also
code review for him so 50 50
3 - good green let's take some
seconds we rest from this
training
I'm a bit agitated and we're back with
Code reviews with much more
technical scenario and let's review with
the group so a few seconds we continue
hello good morning my name is michael
martínez I am from group 7 of our
ideas best place the hardest challenge that
we had
in yesterday on the first day of development
was to formalize the idea or the reija
blankets this is team 6 and the
business yesterday we had a very bacano challenge
that was to create the entire business idea to
messing up we feel really good
hello my name is didier our group
it is agronomy
yesterday we felt good about myself
excellent part because working with the
group as the group shows that we have
a lot of talent to exploit and take out
a product of quality and therefore that can
to really win is the competition
and so
the biggest challenge I say that for us
was to try to define the actual scope of
the application that we wanted then to
Early in the day we had 10,000 ideas
and it touched us
polish to leave something more or more
achievable for the time that I have
I think that after the biggest challenge and because
these two days left alone
give hard to that idea
but my name is or more pray I am the uncle
of recycling recycle yesterday's did not
we feel super good with all the dynamics
and our greatest challenge has been to be able
integrate the google applications of
a very very easy way to our
integration platform project
of recycling
very good we're still in this saying what
he proved 2013 how we really have fun
we were playing with the groups with the
football players here good
he really was as honest as possible
we really gave him the possibility of not
check the code but unfortunately
the team freed but bush won paco
and good to 0 5 to 0 I know it was a landslide
categorical here what we live so
well possibly tomorrow we continue with
this
for what messages do we have in
our social network because I think that already
there are controversial messages there
game that we had will perform patrick
from Argentina accuses you of cheating
I'm not sure because I do not think
they understood the rules but of course yes
of course we have some message there
many words in Spanish that do not
we understand how rudy toxo that good
let's also ask then and what not
late
to see what happens with that in the meantime
his successes following while paco continues
processing the messages its how much
we were presenting competing without how
lift or how to use it as
they lifted a virtual machine how
use the cloud infrastructure what
we made it very simple we generated a
new instance in that distance
we install services those services by
of course in this case use apache that the
web server to justly
visualize good websites then in
this particular case we edit one of the
pages and quickly we could have with
a public ip the solution of what
we had to go back to the
console if while following the camera
spy and there
I'm scared about the spy camera
as I had already asked and of course
apart with this spy camera we
we are seeing how they are performing and
each of the groups so it's very
interesting there the code also we
they are undressing if the cameras
all there but of course nothing happens
because this is pure adrenaline with
we the same with groups and
groups are
being very good as I said
then we have our console that
console that I showed you here
we raise the virtual machine to which
we installed apache what I'm going to do
Now as simple as that, imagine that
I'm using it more by reuters
if I wanted to or directly as I said
I'm going to erase it, so that's how it's simple
with a very very very easy console
I can lift 'virtual machines
install services and perform the
operation you want if it's a linux if a
my disposition in this particular case
so that's the first point that
we had and the other concept that
we always speak are those of tools and
who allow you to do everything because
really when it's not developing
websites it is very important to edit and
see the styles work with the
application performance we have
many utilities of the depto but
I'm going to show good some of the
little things for example to manipulate the
style here we have a very website
simple we have an integration with maps
we are using maps api version 3
very simple but what I wanted them
show is how to use them in pools
good to them I'm opening the console
is showing me the html
we are seeing your successes true yes ok and
in this context, notice that I can go
selecting as I said I have
all the elements if I had
to work them resources
Persistence resources not disconnected
for example good could quickly
visualize them here could come and see
how is it working in local stores
thorax the elector so decision that many
Sometimes it is really important to have it
well in mind and analyze it yes so
could come to visualize here also
as I said network performance
when I'm doing gestures
post how they are performing and good to go
analyzing the performance of my site in
general without seeing I also have to
access the shorts and if I have
javascript as I told you I made a
very simple integration and notice that there
You can see it I'm looking at the site
web this is funded yes but very
quickly the tools allow me
good to identify for example where
I'm taking that image that I'm
placing inside the next track
we want to change it if we can change what
you can change here without any problem
of course we have to have a one
url of an icon of an image and what
we can do
is also awaiting versions and of the
code like I'm going to edit it and that
way it allows me to very quickly operate
If I can also work with profile or
is to see much more performance and how
is working javascript and so
successively audit and work with the
console in general as for example already
we have there is an alert ok
well the point here is if I want
change parts of the styles of
styles of this page
well very quickly could come and
detect for example here and say look
well this is 400 high has 500
of current width I labeling the styles
my site is quickly changing
then I could see how it is going
playing each one of them and
depending on what you play now
I would like to change the background
What would I have to do as I would change?
this style if I want to change the
bar background for that someone from here
you have to know of course we are
talking about basic html abans and
elementary so to you who are
connected there yes yes tell me that I have
what do I do from the tools here
as I'm doing step has a
second trip to california
you never know or know the prize is
says after he answers the sacred
here we are about the regional talent
so the question is what would have to
do in this case using the
sales very easily to work
about the body of this very basic html
to change the background color
let's call the man who said
perfect says I watched him applause
come come come come come with me I followed
taught here is going to be very
interesting has two opportunities to
change the code so there you have it
free if this is seeing it I
I control here and of course if I
he does well he saves himself from the code I know
it can bother him also like in the
soccer so you do not have any
problem is writing
and he managed to imagine that we want it
we want to do so I want a scale of
colors and immense and I want a scale
of colors in pink the background is pink
so to you who are there and to the lord
can achieve it can not achieve what
I want in pink to see what I want to see there
I want to see there are pink or colors
close to the roses to see what can
do I keep looking at the 10 9 8 7 7 6 5 4 3
2 1 and just lost the challenge just
to lose the challenge
congratulations on how you live in this
duel but of course all the
adrenaline of the development vocecita what
it seemed to california
we really had a great time so
reacts well react the ecosystem
Colombian so program together with us
and see how easy it is with tulle
very easy can easy good little bag what
go with the camera to see what is happening
back there I do not know where you're going
ay ay ay ay we see opera cooperates
cooperate cooperate, they cooperate with us
but good
for ccoo we have some more message for
who is looking for carolina
dying
let's look we come to look for
Carolina where is Carolina to see
tell me karina moreno who is that
queen where is the come that urine
come come come come here to see
why do you have who is looking for it
let's see how she is doing
I do not want to create a national contact there
competition
Diego Suarez says you're a cape you're
a layer what is something good good to
see carolina to see a return for
all that audience of guys all over
Latin America that are following you
message there is to speak to the camera to them and
tell him how much you appreciate them well
but I do not appreciate them very much I expect a
plus one in our our group of
cloud and support them because we're going to win
very well take advantage very well in
manipulations that happens in this video
but under what he said to you
that you follow me that you like me
I say such or such thing
jm give me a +1 and obviously of course
movements and that those movements
delete them because they are not part of what
which are sensual movements
the ineffective presenter good we are not going to
take a few seconds and the
traveled by the groups we continue by
course with much more
there you are in the famine
so follow the spy camera by
course we are going to go through the groups and
we are going to close this technical challenge the
scenario dyed with candies and more than
blue in this first but you 2003
vote edition we are going back
the winning group the number 4 good day of
yesterday it was very interesting because there was
quite challenges first of all was how
model the idea that we had at
skills of each member
of group for what
so we could do it fast simple and
how they work then was a
interesting experience because you can
get to see how it's always like
positive any change and see how the
the skills of each person how we
we feel well happy
we are a little bit tired two a
little in sleep but it does not matter
touched and give it right and I think tomorrow
yes we will be like hello I am mario
Moreno and I'm from the Claudio team
good yesterday I felt very good with
many energies the team gave everything
the fish I see everything I had to
do in his role I dedicated myself to design
the brand
the application that we are going to do and the
challenge was to take that presentation in less
half an hour and to have it ready and we
it was very well I think it went very well
it's true we feel confident and we're going
to win
well my name is diana on the day of
yesterday it really was a great experience
I met a lot of people we made groups
it was a challenge to present at the end of the day
everything that we had progressed and then
present it in front of so many people in
youtube well it was a bit gives a bit of
fear the truth but then there goes very
well we're still in this nursery
approved 2013 Bogota edition really
we were watching along this live
how to use the cloud infrastructure
of google using competition and by
course we also saw some flashes
of the tulle we were making a
virtual machine we had configuring the
apache we have playing soccer with the
participants and of course now we're going
to review more groups and so they live
around here while I'm already paco
ask why there are many messages in
the social network many comments so
that's very interesting too but come
and follow me around here, see how they are
programming some of the
developers or the foot in this case
that is very comfortable that is quiet
do not worry come here you live
here we are going to continue traveling
André already asked him had he played
with us they see and they are very
concentrates
to see, I would like to know where the
spy camera we also call back
to that of course sir to see how you
goes
hello very well that comes seems seems from
not of not the state of its development
as the back in comes, the back is good
end we already have it in more than 65
we are working on the
integration of google maps and we already have
the pencil of the mobile web
almost finished ok not deployed in app
in itself that is that language technology
they used to not the
developers are using
cloud technologies for cloud
then do the integration with app
engine ok
let's call Juan Manuel you think
if we talk to Juan Manuel Ok so that
tell us to see if I use to
persist you seem to have come to manel
come with me here, yes, let's ask
let's do as they say in some
new lawyer's day will open
variable way exactly now here to
see sir in that in that they developed the
nail as it comes juan manuel we are
working with the with the google cloud
managing the entire database in the cloud
also supporting us in the sessions
tables for map markers
download as fast ok
since in what language are you programming
a php and or php script I know they're
using the sdk if php or how are they
using mark lowe from google
I am supporting the team in the part
of javascript
July carbó quoted here we call him
julia we will also look for july
July who is doing the part of the
back end
or then doing
call let's call july and fabian
come july and fabian come here
let's detect to see how far it goes
let's see first we talk with the foot
he said we are using the google cloud
that's good news is still brave
we go around perfect after we talk
with Juan Manuel told us that we are already
using the google case I'm
doing javascript my name php
also so well we'll see it here
it's a hybrid that we're using
good
in the application then we're going
we are working on php so then
we need not tremble no no
it was so I had
5 to 2 in the fumes
well then we decide
work our application on php in the
normal server
tell the truth and then I have to
php server we are working
normal consultations that is to be able to
use sql cloud but then now in
the cloud sql needed payment and right now
they collaborated with us with the bonus for
to be able to pass the sdk and deploy our
perfect app app engine ok
although I know that they are going to use as
persistence klaus and what yes clear
although we already have voice successes not
we have neither nor was it necessary to use it to
July here I was praying because I did not
ask for nothing of course very
safe and the criminal wants to play a penalty
already of course they are going to come much more
game here so thank you thank you
there were thanks july course
we have it right here on the back that
is going to say something
say something specific
to see what he was going to tell his companion
come come so that count do not notice
how is his head dressed
and also group strategies cometrans
and he told them he was saying
was measuring the times for the
video
we have a video presentation where
we put all projects between the idea
it was that they supported me little with time
because petit wood hits ok tending yes
yes of course the vice cited is like this
good and very wild and lately
but
and we are
not for more once the stoppage by
Ecuador
close to 70 percent of the dawn that
soon in the front and we do not lack a
little polish some things
ok let's say the design part
structural is already pretty good and
they come
it is also perfect is perfect or
whatever we're programming the
platform that I wanted because the
design we are programming a photoshop
no way
we do not know juan juan comes juan like
we are very well very well in that we are
programming good already took care of the
text net
this is a android is doing the
application from behind and him and the why
well we are using cloud sql or what
thorax clubs I started some images or
that already sent in kings yes today we use
they already compete to fine country there ok
have some preferred imagine that
is looking to if you have any preferred
here
tell me you were looking has some
preference, say, of any of the
participants of the rivero but bush 2013
as if you do not have a reference saw
something that he liked that interested him
thank you to continue in here
of course I almost take everything I can this
but nothing happens next here
it's a little more of the adrenaline
technology that is being lived we are
reviewing each of the projects
we see the breakthrough so we have a
final message of our social network
someone to thank them for
comments
yes good in general here we have a
tight competition between joel arming and
several who are responding to all
the questions and challenges there is a good
competition to see who answers more
quickly that's why everyone to participate
of course thank you very much to you
you're there to all the live audience
that follows us minute by minute
we remember joining the community of
seguinos developers in the portal
first but bush together very well the
presentation of comes the presentation of
the applications of the day
with the backend with the wacken
working so to prepare because
out there by cpm voices and cough
6 pm 6 pm 6 pm Bogota time remember
in the hour use minus 5 we go back with
much more technological adrenaline in this one
developer voice edition bogotá 2013
we come back at 6 with the presentation of
the applications
hello good morning my name is michael
martin I am from group 7 of our ideas
best place the hardest challenge that
we had
yesterday on the first day of development it was
formalize the idea hello I'm jacob and
sasha east of team 6
business yesterday we had a very challenging
low